und jetzt die ganze wut von den nazis
wohl die ganze wut nicht so gut und bin
ich gar nicht ich bin eher guten auf den
lock down als auf annalena baerbock aber
auch das macht mich schon ein wenig
wütend nicht rasen aber würde ich frage
mich ob jetzt haben wir eine
außenministerin anna lena berbalk heißt
was befähigt denn eigentlich eine lena
berbalk dazu außenministerin zu werden
sind wir wirklich einen
grottenschlechten wahlkampf geführt dann
hat sie ihr buch in teilen abgeschrieben
ihr lebenslauf geschönt vergessen
nebeneinkünfte zu melden die liste ist
lang die jetzt jetzt unsere
außenministerin eine frau mit einem
glaubwürdigkeitsproblem in der eigenen
bevölkerung ich frage mich wirklich was
soll das ich finde herausragende ämter
benötigen heraus lange persönlichkeiten
und wenn einer in der werbung in meinen
augen 1 nicht ist ist es heraus
vielleicht darin ich weiß auch nicht ich
würde es ja schon als betrügen sagen
wenn man ein buch in teilen ab schreibt
ich habe es eben schon aufgezählt ich
würde mir wünschen es ist endlich nicht
immer nur noch nach parteipolitik geht
sondern auch nach können und nach
leistung und außen ist in meinen augen
nach dem wahlkampf nach dem desaster in
den letzten monaten wirklich jemand
anderes machen müssen oder können wir
nicht als deutsch erwarten jemanden zu
haben der es schafft einen wasserdichten
lebenslauf hochzuladen
lena ich frage mich manchmal bei der
these so ob ich noch nicht ganz in der
opposition angekommen bin wahrscheinlich
nicht aber ein bisschen muss ich zur
ehrenrettung von annalena baerbock doch
noch sagen ich glaube es hätte auch
schlimmer kommen so also ich finde um
jetzt ein bisschen zur ehrenrettung
beide waren sowie hört ja ernsthaft zu
sagen die annalena baerbock habe ich und
das sache jetzt auch ernsthaft wirklich
als fleißig und diszipliniert
wahrgenommen klar bei der wahl kann für
sie hatte hat sie sicherlich auch fehler
gemacht das ist menschlich aber am ende
glaube ich auch wir haben jetzt vier
jahre genug zeit um in der opposition
auf draufzuhauen dabei ich finde sie
gehört sicherlich zu denen die
jedenfalls mir auch in der
zurückliegenden legislaturperiode ich
war mit ihr auch ab und an
in talksendungen in debatten immer
diszipliniert gut vorbereitet auch und
deswegen ich sage die union hätte
sicherlich bessere minister gestellt
aber ich bin gespannt was da noch so
günter kabinett kommen ich würde da
zustimmen er weil ich finde dass berbalk
kennengelernt als eine politikerin die
sich wahnsinnig mit den außenpolitischen
themen auseinandersetzt ja sie sagt ja
selbst kommt vom völkerrecht da haben
sich viele im wahlkampf drüber lustig
gemacht aber wenn man mit ihr spricht
auch mal nicht im interview sondern ganz
normal dann merkt man wirklich dass zum
beispiel das thema nord-irak jesiden
frauenrechte china nord stream ukraine
wirklich themen wo ich mich auf viel als
reporter bewegt hat waren sich am herzen
liegt ich glaube sie wird der klarere
positionen vertreten als heiko maas viel
klarere positionen als die cdu auch bei
bestimmten namen zum beispiel bei china
und russland da gehe ich ganz ganz stark
von ausspannen wird noch zu sehen sein
spannend wird nur zu sehen sein ob sie
diese position dann gegen olaf scholz
durchsetzen kann der im kanzleramt die
eigentliche außenpolitik macht also ich
finde wenn sie ein amt oder wenn man
hier eine chance geben sollte dann genau
diesem sehr für mich gar kein amt
verdient hätte finden aber sie hat ja
jemand verdient ich hatte ja immer noch
sehr der immer noch prozent dazugewonnen
ist ja nicht so dass
wir jetzt leiht sie hat ja auch die
ganze werbekampagne die man als
kanzlerkandidat kriegt und dafür war das
ergebnis der grünen ist weit unter den
erwartungen geblieben übrigens nicht nur
bundestagswahlkampf sie hat ein
direktmandat errungen also ich frage
mich halt bei annalena baerbock wirklich
wo jetzt dort die qualifikation dafür
liegt zum beispiel robert habe der sie
als vize kanzler geworden und wird jetzt
auch das ministerium übernehmen für
wirtschaft und ja auch klima und da muss
ich sagen ich bin kein fan der grünen
aber ich habe robert habeck in den
letzten monaten schon schätzen gelernt
indem ich gesehen habe er ist nicht wie
söder und tritt nach öffentlich sondern
hält sich zurück und hat mit ihr
zusammen agiert das fand ich toll ich
habe respekt vor robert habeck gewann
robert habeck hat für mich an
glaubwürdigkeit gewonnen aber die
glaubwürdigkeit hat doch da muss man den
zustimmt letzten wollten gelindert und
allen erwerb absoluten aber wie man ein
bisschen wasser in den wein von robert
habeck oder auch in der kultur
robert habeck hat annalena baerbock am
abend der bundestagswahl eiskalt
abrasiert als in der berliner runde saß
und dann wahrscheinlich keine ahnung
dass über die faz noch zusätzlich
gespielt hat dass er vizekanzler wird
das ist alles auf ihn zuläuft also das
hat er nur einmal gemacht und nicht
nachgetreten das ist richtig aber er hat
ganz klar in der wahlnacht die chance
ergriffen und das was er eigentlich
wollte sich zum spitzenmann in diesem
duo erklärt und/oder zuspitzen personen
vielmehr und klar gemacht wo da der mann
ein wort zu außenministerin selbst man
kann deutschland nicht nur mit
menschenrechten regieren auch nicht nach
außen hin das ist ein hehres ziel das
müssen die grünen auch tun ein beispiel
mercedes hat im letzten jahr mehr autos
verkauft in china als im ganzen rest der
welt da kommen sagen das ist alles ein
unrechtsstaat oder was auch immer man
muss aber anerkennen dass das so ist und
wer die außenpolitik oder
kann diesen realitäten vorbei macht der
wird es schwer haben glaube ich auch auf
deutschland zu bestehen und ich habe
aber gar keine sorge dass das so ist
denn das auswärtige amt hat bei seinen
15 bisherigen außenministern wenn wir
aber auch noch dazu rechnen die ja in
personalunion beides war die ersten vier
jahre
tatsächlich ist immer geschafft sich die
ministerin bisher die erste berliner
bürgermeister so zu backen wie das amt
ist denn will und am besten war das
auswärtige amt immer wenn es gefordert
wurde von hans dietrich genscher etwa
von joschka fischer der das außerdem
selbst gefordert oder auch von sigmar
gabriel aber das amt braucht jemanden
der da immer nach vorne will und ob sie
das schaffte da wird jedes ihrer
forderung nach klima klima klima und
menschen rechnet das werden wir sehen
noch eine frage und schon ist er ihnen
sie haben das ja also das war fast nur
total vernichtung sowie sind wir gewohnt
weil es ja normal ok ich frage auch nur
nach einer erweiterung sie sagen doch
gar nicht dass es keine außenministerin
grund haben sie gesagt was du in der
politik zu suchen das ist das so schlimm
tatsächlich so ich glaube bei ich sage
aber deswegen extra die these gemacht
herausragende ämter benötigen
herausragende persönlichkeit ich finde
zum beispiel frau berg ist ein gutes
vorbild für junge frauen ich habe sie
nur weder als kanzlerin gesehen noch als
außenminister rio würden sie sie sehen
ich glaube dass frau berbalk ich jetzt
also das finde ich ein bisschen wenn ich
jetzt hier in beruflicher ratschlag
geben dazu will ich mich jetzt ehrlich
gesagt nicht hinreisen lassen
nicht aber ich glaube zum beispiel mal
ein direktmandat herum zu haben dass man
in china waren ja nicht so leicht davon
wind und brand muss
jetzt am montag der linie tanja hat er
gesagt das direktmandat und da würde man
auch sagen wir heute diesen schweren
gregor gysi gekoppelt hat weiß ich noch
nicht ob
man meint mit frau berben ich frage mich
generell warum wir die diese diese diese
was man erringen muss wenn man coo von
unternehmen werden will dann muss man
meistens erst mal jahre lang gearbeitet
haben jahrzehnte lang muss expertise
mitbringt warum wird für die politiker
die leiste so aber muss es so laut sagen
wo ja so leicht die einstellung ja auch
sein ist bei den namen die genannt
wurden bei den grünen da ist null
vielfalt dabei bislang also alles was
gehandelt wird ist weiß und und das
finde ich interessant weil man käme ja
beim aussenamt vor vier jahren wäre sie
haben müsste mir außenminister geworden
bei dem ich auch sagen würde der ist von
den beiden geeignet zb auch in mindmaps
wie sehen sie die frage ums
außenminister also jetzt jam oder lena
ich meine dass das außenamt ein ganz
zentrales amt ist aber ich gehe in die
richtung die béla anda gerade skizziert
hat es geht darum sprech fähig zu sein
es geht irgendwo vielleicht auch um
positionen aber das ist eigentlich schon
der job des bundeskanzlers
man muss eine sprechfähigkeit und hinter
den kulissen auch mechanismen
installieren dies die konflikte lösen
beispiel sigmar gabriel der den
türkischen außenminister in großer
empfangen hat und wo von heute noch
spricht und ich hoffe dass türkische
außenminister damals wahrscheinlich war
ich beeindruckt gewesen von grasland
mich an das ist ja auch schöner markt
würde ich das nicht ohne grund was sie
was ich sagen will es ist eine komplexe
sache es ist sehr viel was man leisten
muss was man an charakterlicher eignung
mit sich bringen muss und das war ja
gerade eine imposante liste an
außenministern die wir hatten aber ich
kann das nicht an diese missratenen buch
festmachen und ihren lebenslauf den ein
völlig überforderter
parteiapparat zu verantworten hat ich
hätte die vermutlich wenn ich jetzt
selber gewesen der rausgeschmissen und
wenn man den grünen etwas vorwerfen
möchte dann dass sie an diesem punkt
vielleicht zu last sind aber dass das
sind das wissen sie doch auch wie man
von mitarbeitern abhängig ist aber ich
bin den rest kann sie mitbringen es kann
auch sein dass sie ihn nicht mitbringt
aber das haben wir schon mehrfach erlebt
und wir haben diese ruckeln bei neuen
regierungen ja auch in schröder fischer
war ein fehler sein der lebenslauf wurde
ja beschädigt also ich würde jetzt nicht
sagen dass mitarbeiter sich hingesetzt
und gedacht hat wie stelle ich sie
besser da
wir sollten sozusagen in der ebene jetzt
auch wenn man sich fragt herr opposition
was kritisiere ich dann an dieser neuen
regierung da fällt mir eine
aussenpolitik einiges einer wenn einige
themen kommen bilder an da hat einiges
skizziert werden mit der
migrationspolitik wo sie als
außenministerin wörtchen mitzusprechen
hat sicherlich harte konflikte haben
wenn ich da sehe die schnittstellen
zwischen innen- und außenpolitik wie
geht man mit belarus um wir werden nach
außenministerin berbalk daran messen
müssen wie kann sie das was sie zur
klimapolitik sagt denn auch im rest der
welt vielleicht umsetzen wir werden
sehen müssen dass außenpolitik eben
nicht nur menschenrechte ist sondern
auch wirtschaftspolitik freihandel die
themen da würde ich sie eher kritisieren
oder werde ich sie glaube ich auch noch
sehr kritisieren in den nächsten vier
jahren als jetzt sozusagen da ewig im
rückspiegel darum ich will jetzt hier
nicht in die geschichte eingehen
sozusagen als der größte fan verteidigen
kann der leser berbalk aber ich glaube
die kritik muss er an den inhalten an
sitzen und wir tun auch gut daran wenn
wir auf der ebene glaube ich kritisieren
und da gibts genug angriffsfläche wenn
ich diesen koalitionsvertrag überfliege
und es gibt die politischen sieht noch
ganz kurz die canon philipp antwort
natürlich genauso die frau war
parteivorsitzende sie war
spitzenkandidatin sie hat auch mit einem
wirklich nach unten gegenden ergebnis
sie lagen ja vor der spd lange zeit auf
platz eins die grünen in die regierung
geholt nach der politischen wäre hat so
jemand dann anrecht auf ein minister
innen amt so einfach ist das so einfach
ist das sagt béla anda und jetzt bevor
wir zu einem weiteren thema gehen von
peter pauls muss ich noch mal ganz kurz
wir uns ganz viele user geschrieben
haben philipp am tor um auch beim thema
werbung sie sind in dieser woche
aufgefallen so ein bisschen mit einem
urteil zum rasen
mit jahr 20 durch die fuß gefasst so
viel ich kenne das ja jetzt sagt ich
habe gepunktet ich ärgerte mich ganz
schön darüber aber so ist das wieland
dürfen jetzt nicht warnt hier ich vier
wochen vier wochen aber dann sind wir
schon drüber reden ich meine ich jetzt
trotzdem also sie sind doch ein
erfahrener politiker sie wissen also mir
hat mal jemand gesagt als ich ins amt
wieder alles was wir machen wird
öffentlich das war der beste rat den ich
bekommen habe sie wissen dass das
öffentliche mir trotzdem haben sie
gesagt ich versuche mal da vorbei zu
kommen und so zu tun was viele menschen
in der wirtschaft tatsächlich machen
wenn sie ertappte ich bin gar nicht
gefahren jemand der so bekannt ist wie
sie muss doch wissen dass das
skandalisiert wird und dass ihnen wieder
sowas um den hals gehängt wird habe sich
entschuldigt schon ja ich habe mich
geärgert ich habe es rechtlich prüfen
lassen rechtsanwalt hat gesagt so eine
gute idee war weiter hat auch jetzt will
das ist eine gute idee die
rechtsbeschwerde einzulegen ich habe es
nicht gemacht ist